für mich ist halt wie so eine
auswechsellose Situation
ich beständig in Gefahr ich eigentlich
gar nicht mehr ich muss irgendwo Haare
in Sicherheit leonie hat jahrelang
gemeint sie werden vor unbekannten Täter
rituell missbraucht
aus Herzen
entstanden sind die falsche Erinnerung
psychiatrische Klinik Nächte lang als
Bett gefesselt
präventiv will grüss sie Therapeutin
Leonie auf Grundlage von der
verschwörungserzählung behandelt hat
unsere Recherche zeigen nicht nur mit
Therapeutin und Erz haben sich in der
verschwörungsstelle verloren als
Staatsanwaltschaft Polizei und Cash
aufhören
Leonie weiss dass sie nicht Opfer von
rituellen Gewalt sondern von euch
Verschwörung mir ihre fallen auf ich
fand es extrem schlimm wenn irgendetwas
nicht existiert
es dreht sich alles wieder nur um die
ganze Gewalt und entspannt findet und
der ganze Code was nicht
was macht wirklich
Psychiatriezentrum Münsingen sieht mir
zu satanic Panic recherchieren mit ihrem
Kontakt Leonie wird in die Klinik über
Wochen jede Nacht als Bett fixiert ich
habe die letzte Nacht mehrfach
Seite müssen wir also bitte fixieren
ist Leonie tatsächlich fixiert wurde
will Ärztinnen sind sie würden von
unbekannte Täter bedroht werden
hallo schön jetzt klappt das gefunden
können
und es gab Leonie wieder deutlich besser
sie bringt ein Teil von ihren Akte mit
austrittsbericht und Gutachten
die Ärztin
Leonie wurde für die Sekte gezeugt und
für die Sekte von klein auf programmiert
mehrmals fanden auch sodomistische
Rituale Stadt die Täter verlustieren
sich selber an den Kälbern später wird
Leonie gefilmt wenn sie von einem Hund
der vorher aufgeilt wurde penetriert
wird für die Penetration durch ein Pferd
wird sie auf einem Tisch platziert in
voll und Lärm und Nächten treffen sich
die Männer in schwarzen Kutten und roten
Augen auf dem Friedhof sie bringen im
Kofferraum nackte Mädchen mit eines der
Mädchen muss einen Fötus Schlachten das
Blut wird zu Reinigung getrunken das
kleine Herz gegessen bist du in rese
ganz normal ohne irgendwelche religiöse
satanistische
uni-effekte was auch immer gar nicht mit
Mami ist ganz normal Mini älterer
gar nicht mit irgendeiner Sekte zu tun
als Jugendliche ist Leonie psychisch
krank geworden später hätten
Traumatherapie machen so ist sie zu der
Traumatherapeutin
bist du zu den Therapeutin Hobbys hast
du noch nie ein bisschen satanistische
rituelle Missbrauch gehört gar nicht
also irgendwie im Fernsehen oder
irgendwo sich glaube dann hat einfach
noch gar kein Thema
ist es erste der Traumatherapie
ist während 7 Jahre
sie hat am Schluss gehabt sie werden
rituell missbraucht und vor unbekannte
Täter verfolgt ihre Traumatherapeutin
ist so tief in dem verschwörungswandern
dass Sie immer wissen
sie von der unbekannte Täter quält
werden
live Englisch
und ich sehe da aber auf WhatsApp
Nachrichten
wo ihr da hin und her geschrieben hat
also das ist ja also das ist übergriffig
ist dass sie dich trackt aber auch die
Stanzen zwischen euch oder das
Miteinander
los und das hat mir da irgendwo am
Anfang zumindest
und so wenig Abhängigkeit
gemacht irgendwie so gefühlt ohne die
Therapeutin im Leben
gesagt
Kalender je nach Datum wird halt den
Kopf frei oder den ich nur quasi das
Frauen mit Tieren
Schnitt
aus herzblutung gemacht
Internet sage aber irgendwo habe ich mir
auf jeden Fall schlecht gefühlt wo ist
nicht so ganz gewusst habe ich doch
gemacht
mir hat Traumatherapeutin von der Leonie
mit dem Vorwurf konfrontiert sie hätte
Leonie fehltherapiert und so Situation
von der Leonie dramatisch verschlechtert
weil sie offensichtlich an die
verschwörungserzählung
ich weise die erhobenen Vorwürfe
entschieden zurück die Vorwürfe
verkennen insbesondere dass die
Auseinandersetzung mit Standpunkten
einer Patientin ein zentraler Teil jeder
psychotherapeutischen Behandlung ist und
nicht mit der Anerkennung dieser
Standpunkte durch die behandelnde Person
zu verwechseln ist sie seit 40 Jahren
versetzt und das alles gar nicht glaub
das kann alles verliert wenn sie das
nicht glaubt hat warum hat sie denn ein
Arzt dir unbekannte theaterschaft
gemacht sie hat mir auch Südafrika
geschickt in der Schutz Aufenthalt damit
die gestanzt hat zu der Theater warum
hat sie die Bücher
also es macht es macht überhaupt keinen
Sinn wenn man das nicht
man hat natürlich noch gefragt was ich
auf der Seite
für Therapeutin ist die angebliche
Bedrohung von einer unbekannte Täter aus
Gott offenbar so real gesehen dass sie
mehrere Gefährdungsmeldungen
schutzbehörde gemacht hätte es besteht
eine latente Gefährdung aus Hinweisen
aus der Therapie ist nicht
auszuschließen dass die Patientin im
Rahmen von kultritualen auch anderen
Menschen Gewalt antut aus
therapeutischer Sicht ist es wichtig die
Patientin länger mehrere Wochen bis
Monate vor Übergriffen von Tätern zu
schützen Schutz vor Gewalt sowie vor den
ständigen Programmierungen bis sie
besser stabilisiert ist
Staatsanwaltschaft Sonne tun es
Strafverfahren gegen Unbekannt ich
gleitet
also sehr schön
übersichtlich
irgendwie
Videos sagt also Video Aufnahmen machen
ähm wo nicht denn aber eigentlich recht
schnell abgebrochen habe wenn man aus
Opfer die darmsen
Mutter und jüngere Schwester von der
leonie hat sich der Name
hallo hallo sie zeigt ihres Gesicht
nicht wenn sie aber angestellt dass
Anhänger
auf Wunsch oder leonie ist ganz
gemütliche vier Tage
zwei drei Wochen
ist also wenn sie gegangen genau
aber ganz genau wissen wenn es
tatsächlich so Eifer Name
dazu leonie hat Akten von der
Staatsanwaltschaft Solothurn abforderte
leonie ist also tatsächlich von der
Staatsanwaltschaft Solothurn observiert
wurde ihre wird das alles Ziel sie kommt
mit Ilona spazieren während ich mir die
Akte genau
[Applaus]
macht was ich real,-
rituelle Wahnsinn hätte bitte Stopp
Therapeutin von der Leonie hätte
Kantonspolizei regelmäßig über
therapiesitzige informiert sie hat über
100 WhatsApp Nachrichten und E-Mails
geschrieben oder weitergeleitet zum
Beispiel schreibt Therapeutin im
Kantonspolizisten
Abschlussfest und Mond meistens sind
wohnrituale laut Patientin bei Friedhof
Burg und finden zur dunklen Stunde statt
also nach Mitternacht
kurze Info heute Abend in einem Puff
Treffen geplant runder Tisch genannt das
Mädchen tanzt auf dem Tisch Männer
bieten Geld der meist bietende kommt
dann zuerst dran und darf machen mit dem
Mädchen was er will dann der nächste
Mann außerdem in Ukraine sei ein Mann
der Gruppierung verhaftet worden einer
der drei großen dort vom Ring
verrückt die Kantonspolizei ist noch
eine schräge Hinweis von der Therapeutin
noch gegangen und nach Abschluss von den
Ermittlungen wird eisglas klar dass die
von Leonie gemeldeten Ereignisse und
Übergriffe zu einem hohen Prozentsatz
komplett ausgeschlossen werden können
die Untersuchungsbehörden konnten kein
einziges treffen oder Ereignis zum
Nachteil von Leonie feststellen trotz
der erkanntnis ist der Fall von der
Leonie bis heute nur offen mein
Staatsanwaltschaft Solothurn mit dem
konfrontiert und sie fragt wieso sieht
Leonie aufgrund von der
verschwörungserzählung observiert haben
und Telefon abgeschossen haben im Rahmen
des Strafverfahrens wurden
verschiedenste Ermittlungshandlungen
vorgenommen um die geäußerten
Tatvorwürfe zu überprüfen
praxisgemäß können jedoch zu einzelnen
Ermittlungshandlungen eines laufenden
Verfahrens keine Auskünfte erteilt
werden
Therapeutin von der leonie hat hier
verschwörungst erzähle ich hätte keine
glauben das war man mit dem Jerome
Endras besprechen er ist forensische
Psychologen und Experte für Extremismus
wie kann das sie das Psychotherapeuten
aufgrund von der
verschwörungstherapieren
Gesellschaft hätten auch sprachbarkeit
und verschwörungserzählungen
und dann ist das Wetter verwunderlich
dass man das selber Psychotherapeutin
und Psychotherapeuten
zeigen dass ihr intelligente Menschen
sind desto weniger sie doch aussprechen
ob man so neidisch zu esoterischen
Glauben hat
wie stark ausgeprägt haben sind
verschiedene Faktoren aus dem Bereich
von Intelligenz und von der
Persönlichkeit wo am Schluss ein eher
dazu disponieren
Verschwörung zu erzählen oder halt
weniger Verschwörung nicht in der
Psychiatrie in der Medizin allgemein und
ihre Psychotherapie verloren sie sind
nur destruktiv wieso hat man denn die
Verschwörung immer wieder übernommen
ich danke ganz vieles davon ist nicht
bewusst passiert ich denke ganz vieles
davon sind wo danktant sie machen
richtige Job mit dem Sie einfach das
übernommen hat was geschrieben hat was
ist das effektiv toxische Verschwörung
das wenn man mal die sagt xetisch das
viele nach behandeln die gar nicht mehr
merken dass sie auf Grundlage von der
Verschwörung erzähle
oder entsprechende
[Musik]
leon ist das genauso passiert man hätte
Verschwörung einfach immer wieder immer
wieder
Therapeutin hat sie zu BerufskollegInnen
wo die damalige leiten die Ärztin von
der Privatklinik Meiringen geschrieben
hat ich Ihnen Psychiatrie ist Gutachten
psychisch offenbar hat niemand das
Schriftstück hinterfragt nach diesem
Klinikaufenthalt erfolgte durch die
Täter eine intensive nachprogrammierung
mittels Strom und Drogen l möchte aus
der Sekte aussteigen sie wurde mehrmals
von ihrer Mutter und ihre Schwester zu
internationalen satanistischen treffen
begleitet an denen sie sexuelle Wünsche
erfüllen musste während Mutter und
Schwester einen Stadtbummel erlebten
die ehemalige leiten die Ärztin von der
Privatklinik Meiringen
ist mehrmals Station
behandelt worden du willst sagen
also definitiv also therapiert hat
man auch also
dort wohne auf jeden Fall
dass es dir überhaupt gibt ja eigentlich
heißen
gar nicht danke
verantwortlich ärztlich direkt gefragt
mein Führungsverständnis passiert auf
Vertrauen nicht Kontrolle ich setze
deshalb voraus dass diese Fachpersonen
leitende Position entsprechend dem
wissenschaftlichen fachstandard arbeitet
sowie handelt und ich diese
Führungsperson vertrauen kann
Leonie auch für ihre Familie sind die
vergangene 7 Jahre der Horror
ihre Schwestern Carmen erinnert sich an
das Gespräch mit dem Thomas Reisch im
ehemalige ärztliche Direktor von
Psychiatriezentrum Münsingen
mehrmals Station
betroffen
bin oder immerhin ein Überbringer
verbotschafter ich hatte sauber gemacht
passiert ist bin ich aufgewachsen
ich bringe das von mir du Zeit wird
präsentiert wird von der Klinik
im Leben das passt für mich nicht ich
bin gesunde Person und ich sehe dir
Problem wo Klinik seht im Umfeld und
eben wenn das ein Arzt im Seiten
existiert wieso Körper wo psychisch
abgeschlagen ist wo jetzt im Fall von
meiner Schwester schon bejah das
idrichter bekommt dass der datenkreis
existiert den
du als betroffene Personen
behandeln
schon vorher im Sommer 22 hätte der
mitteilt dass er unter anderem war der
Führungsschwäche als ärztliche direkt
auf der Abteilung Angst und Depression
entlaufen oder nicht obwohl du gezwungen
auch mal jemanden sage ich mal zu töten
ja
ja ganz häufig also ich glaube in diesem
Rahmen ist das auch schon fast Standard
youtube ist voll von Frauen
rituelle satanistische Missbrauch
erlaubt und hätte mir sicher zum Teil
auch Herzen Asse also wirklich völlig
verrückt der rituell satanistische
Missbrauch wo die sich adrenochrom holen
wo die die Kinder traumatisieren wo die
natürlich die Kinder schwanger und
wieder füllten zu haben sie meine Lehrer
darunter waren auch Ärzte dieses Ritual
hat eigentlich dazu gedient dass ich mit
Satan vermählt werde ich musste dann
diese diese Frau und dieses Kind
umbringen das alles sei nur eine
Verschwörungstheorie mittels und bis zum
Schubladen Journalismus werden in diese
Serie all die Zeugen und Opfer als
unglaubwürdig dargestellt
zurück zu der Leonie wir sind auf dem
Weg zum Psychiatriezentrum münsingen
[Musik]
obwohl sie ja fragen wie ist der
verantwortlich von der Casper zurück
dass sie die Maßnahmen aufgrund von der
verschwörungserzählung
und trotzdem da in die Klinik zu
Münsingen ist Leonie zum Schutz vor der
unbekannten Täter Aspekt fixiert wurde
die Verantwortlichen
vor der Kamera keiner zum Fall von der
Leonie aus Persönlichkeitsschutzgründen
glaube
Psychiatrie in der Schweiz
bis sich das Gutachten Dezember 21
bedienstadt es kann stark davon
ausgegangen werden dass der heutige
täterkontakt wie er von Frau berichtet
wird stattfindet und das Frau immer noch
massive Gewalt ausgeliefert ist
der Grund warum das man mehr fixiert hat
ich fixiert auf das Bett und ich will da
die Therapie für offizielle von Pilze
der Münsingen zeigen die Patientin darf
auf die Nacht fixiert werden wenn sie
dies zum Schutz braucht die Fixierung
bleibt jeweils bis am Morgen auch wenn
gewisse Anteile in der Nacht gelöst
werden wollen die Patientin wird nicht
rechtlich gegen die pzm-ag vorgehen wenn
sie im Verlauf mit den oben genannten
Punkten nicht mehr einverstanden ist ja
eigentlich
immer im Bett im Zimmer gesehen und drei
Wochen
eigentlich grundlos was man gar nicht
darf also aufgrund dass du sie haben
genau also eigentlich präventiv und der
Wäsche hat einfach gerade Arme ab und
der links rechts oder links rechts
sondern einfach
fixiert dass du dir sagen
sondern was präventiv sind das ja
eigentlich Basis von der Therapie für
drin steht
fixiert wird und nicht also
und zwar außerhalb Europa
und zwar haben sie geschrieben
empfohlene Maßnahmen für dich und zwar
ein schutzaufenthalt in einem sicheren
Bezirk außerhalb der realen oder
erlebten gefürchteten Reichweite der
Täterschaft außerhalb Europas wie zum
Beispiel in einer Gastfamilie in
Südafrika die Dauer ist schwer
vorauszusagen kann gut 1 bis 2 Jahre
oder länger notwendig sein
genau
gut möglich dass es aber passiert ist
ich hatte der Untersuchungsbericht vor
mir wurde Vorgang am PCM Münsingen genau
Therapie Therapeutinnen der dies
intensivpatientinnen glauben dass die
Patientinnen von Tätern und Tätergruppen
über lange Zeit ihres Lebens intensiver
folgt bedroht überwacht und misshandelt
werden objektive Beweise dafür dass Real
feststellbare Verletzungen wirklich von
Dritten zugefügt worden können nicht
erbracht werden das liege gemäß den
Therapeutinnen daran dass diese Täter
äußerst raffiniert vorgehen und außerdem
Verbindungen zu höchsten Polizei und
Justizkreisen hätten bei dieser
Überzeugung handelt es sich um
Vorstellungen die nach meinem Eindruck
wesentlich stärker bei den
Therapeutinnen ausgeprägt sind als bei
dem Patientinnen selbst die letzte Trio
Patientinnen
zu einzelnen Fall wie dem von der Leonie
wird die Klinik direkt immer noch nicht
sagen
wir keine Form von Verschwörungstheorie
und keine entsprechenden Therapien
persönlich auch eine interne Analyse bei
uns zeigt das Thema hat bei einigen
Intensivpatienten und Patienten mit
Trauma folgen und Borderline Störungen
in der Behandlung eine Rolle gespielt
falls Patientinnen
Pressekonferenz abschließen wenn die
Maßnahmen getroffen die Diagnose von
Dissoziative Identitätsstörung darf nur
noch vom Chefarzt gestellt werden es
geht ein neues stationskonzept und sind
natürlich auch personelle Konsequenzen
kann bedeutet es gibt neue Leute neue
Mitarbeitende
jetzt einfach haben eine andere Art
genau so wieder therapiert
es war Woche später hättet Leonie mit
der Verantwortlichen vom
Psychiatriezentrum Münsingen das hinter
verschlossene Tür wir holen
[Musik]
sie Anziehsachen
und
ja
Entschuldigung mit einem
Gespräch sagen
die ganze Geschichte mit Leonie macht
mich unglaublich traurig vor allem dass
ich nie mehr getraut hätte
entschuldige für die fehlentherapie wo
definitiv gleich geworden
Hilfe Psychotherapie suchen noch mehr
geschädigt werden
wir müssen nämlich wo die Therapie
stattfindet und wäre dahinter steckt
wenn ich das interessiert dann abonniert
doch heute Kanal